[Music]
[Applause]
okay
so one two one two
okay that seems to be
testing testing live stream audio
this is about 30 seconds behind
[Music]
so
one two testing testing one
two this is a sound check
one two one two
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah just just to remind you all that we
are live streaming
and it started now thank you
heads up
all right good afternoon and welcome to
the road utilities and roading committee
it was being held in the function room
and rang rangiora town hall
on tuesday the 15th of september
2020 apologies please
now apologies right move on then um
conflict of interest anybody have any
conflict interests on this
particular meeting all right so we'll
move on then um we'll go with
um confirmation of minutes these witches
on
thank you good thank you anything that
anyone wants to discuss
matters arising on it
no all those in favor please say hi i
think against carrie think anyone
wishing to bring up anything that's
rising from the minutes
yes do you want to
turn your light on please okay
thank you uh just on page nine of the
minutes
um colin confirmed that three waters
would be submitting a report on leakage
across the whole supply network
for a future meeting is there a date for
that
today oh okay
apologies that's all right thank you yes
see philip
uh just one question from kelly uh
whether there'd be any update on the
water safety
plans
so yeah
there's one more safety plan that we've
provided
[Music]
or if they are about to be approved
uh they also indicated that all
large water supplies as well as water
suppliers with
uncoordinated water or without a
residual disinfection
were written to in october 2019
about the requirement to submit water
safety plans
under the framework we did not
receive that letter as
the other thing that we are aware of is
that
at a national level it appears that
the drinking water assessors
are using a consultancy called white
employee
to moderate all
water safety plans approval and i think
that's particularly so for large
suppliers potentially as well as
suppliers that
do not have residual disinfection so
um
the next one um
uh do we have any submitted at the
moment
pending approval um
okay thank you just want to do you want
to go down that bottom and
sit there for presentations shortly yeah
both yeah thank you um
right there's no any deputations and
presentations none
that i know of no
thank you now we'll move on
to um propose
closure of stock water race um
libya and kelly thank you
got a gun cool um
this report seeks approval to close
stockholders r3 k2a
which is a 1.6 kilometer long
portion of the scheme that runs
predominantly adjacent to siena place
it's the terminal end of the scheme
which ends at
bradley's road it's understood that the
channel has been predominantly dry for
the last two years
and as part of the report in the process
we
identified 15 affected parties 10 of
those
provided feedback 8 and support to
an opposition and one of the
parties in opposition that just had
noted some flooding concerns
but obviously as part of any
applications to fill in any portions of
the race
drainage staff will assess any
flood effect so um that consideration is
um thought to be mitigated through that
process um
and obviously where the drainage and
stock water channel
are combined we wouldn't be um allowing
any filling in of that portion
any questions
thank you oh did you want
yeah advance right yes yeah
heavy look and you've got one person
opposed to it um
[Music]
with the water race with um
uh their insurance with um flooding and
all that
have we looked into that is that a a
genuine um
reason for them having that there
i haven't looked into their statement
um however we're assuming that
if it isn't going to cause any adverse
drainage or flood effects
that that wouldn't be an issue so
drainage staff will assess
if they come in for application to fill
it so
they've put here they're opposed to um
the um water race um of their flood
control
um uh where is it
so we haven't looked into those people
that um
put feedback on them
so the person that opposed it if you
turn to page 30
of the agenda there's a plan there that
shows
two properties um one at the end of
siena place
number 67 and the other one at the end
of it believe it's villano place
um so you may be able to make out so
their main concern
is um the water race channel
along the in the northern boundary or
northwest boundary
um and their concern is at the moment if
that we close that race that potentially
could get filled in
you might be able to make out from that
plan that there's a dashed
green line that also superimposes on top
of the blue line
so what will actually happen is that
when the water race closes
that blue line status will disappear
then it will be shown as a drain
maintained by council so their concerns
about
if we remove the status of the water
race um
they just want to make sure that it's
not going to adversely affect the
drainage and in this case
it will be retained as a drain and a
drain that council maintains to ensure
that it functions
adequately into the future
thank you in one other question on it
have we surveyed any other
potential problems um with closing this
water race
um uphill or downhill from this area as
well
and i think kelly before the answer
actually knows where i'm trying to
come from um it's fair to say
and look also looking at page 30 you
will be
you will be able to note that you can
see these locations where the
the blue line and the green dash line
superimpose on top of each other
so that's where it's a combined water
race and drainage channel at the moment
and
there are other locations where the
water race is
separate to the drainage channel
so the key thing that we need to make
sure is
um where they are are combined at the
moment that race will
the drainage channel will not be able to
full be filled in in the future
where it's purely just the water race
there's the ability for it to be filled
in
but in considering whether we can fill
it in we need to make sure that
that's not going to create any localized
issues that if you fill in the channel
that flow will occur um out to the road
and into the
road drainage system um the other thing
is part of that there may even be a
sequencing or order
so we can't have a downstream
property fill in a race before an
upstream property does because
that might actually be the point of
discharge for
upstream properties so it's going to
require drainage staff working closely
with the with any landowners that do
actually want to fill in their water
races to make sure
there aren't any um unintended drainage
issues that arise from this
uh philip thank you
i note that only eight of the 15
resident
support closure i just wondered what
level of support do you
require in order to recommend closure
as far as i'm aware we don't have like a
set percentage
but the remainder didn't provide any
feedback
so eight in support but then also
five silent that didn't provide in the
month any feedback on it
madam chair um i know that we're going
out
for a stock water supply by law review
as a special consultative procedure
can you just update on the time frame
for that um and
well clearly we're still considering
closures while we're preparing
information for that review and is that
going to continue
so two questions
and we actually just had a meeting about
the bible review
and so we're still intending on meeting
the june
2021 um approximate time frame
for conducting their special
consultative
procedure and um getting public feedback
and was the second of the question
was are we well clearly because you've
got this here we
appear to be considering closures
and will that continue yes as far as
yeah under the current rules we'd have
to assess
based on what we currently have
available
just further further today what staff
have also undertaken particularly with
the water zone committee
and environment canterbury is we will
provide an annual report
through to them on total changes in the
previous 12 months
to our stock watery system so
the key point of that is
while we acknowledged that the water
race system
is leaky and that does provide a benefit
to aquifer recharge
we have a total of about 130 kilometers
of
water races within the district and we
want to make sure that
any um while we're not going to stop
closures
we want to track them and monitor to
make sure the net effect of
any beneficial aquifer recharge is not
compromised
and what we have done is looked
back to when the race system was
uh or the irrigation system was
originally put in back in 1999
and we've got stats that actually show
what the
changes have been over the past 20 or so
years to the overall watery system so
while there have been
um closures they are relatively minor
compared to the total
length of races and our discussions with
with ecan and the zone committee have
been that at
at the moment we do not have any plans
to undertake
large scale closures of the stock watery
system
that report when will we get the first
one we haven't had a first one have we
no apart from mintch uh providing a
verbal um update to the zone committee
um we haven't um presented that
to in a in a report format but we would
be
happy to take one to um
the land and water committee this
calendar year okay
me dan did you wish to ask for another
question just in light of
what um council stewart asked
and given that we're in a review is
there any reasons why you
well sorry is there any reason why you
wouldn't consider this laying on the
table
pending the review of the stockholder
race by law
and the interim or do you feel you've
got adequate grounds in which to
continue to recommend to us to proceed
in the
along the line that you recommended
um so our recommendation would be to
proceed with
uh approving the closure of the this
stock water race um this this originally
uh was initiated by
uh the landowners in the area they
wanted the race closed um it was
initially picked up
by wymac irrigation limited to engage
with some of the
uh landowners and then formerly taken
over by
libby to to progress and consult with
the effective landowners
we have actually had some feedback
already
as into the protracted process
um to actually get it closed um
and we have uh advised the landowners
that we do have a formal process to go
through
so our recommendation would be to
proceed with the closure
i think in terms of the bylaw review um
that that
that is a um a key consideration
we're not at the moment we're not
suggesting to make any changes to the
bylaw as part of acknowledging the
environmental benefit of aquifer
recharge
we're looking at bringing a report to
unr in november
asking for approval to consult on that
so that will give you a better flavor at
that point in time
regarding um the aquifer recharge side
of things
any other questions
thank you and i'll second that thank you
oh sorry i i moved yep
and and i seconded it
i've just been moving um madam chair
just want to acknowledge the efforts
that have gone in by staff and this and
it's quite an extensive process as
has been outlined so i just like to
commend
uh libby on the work that's been
undertaken here
um i don't like closing services uh
if we don't need to but in this instance
it's clear where the landowners
have requested it's been through an
exercise where you have the water race
advisory group
and also the ops for the hoka community
board
also um supporting this it's it's been
through quite a thorough process here
and as was mentioned in the uh report
it talked about there's now a large
number of lifestyles
uh through the year it's conversion
today and it's no longer required for
stop water
it's been initiated by the land owners
as well
the other reason that was and
was well put is that there will still be
the drain
drainage will still be maintained
through there
it would have been a concern to me if
that hadn't have been the case
given the issues that we had some years
ago i'm sure we'd have a resident very
nearby that would be giving us some
fairly direct feedback if we hadn't been
in rightly so
because drainage is an issue of concern
in that community
um so that i'm i'm supportive of it
um and i think we've done our homework
on it so thanks to the staff for the
work
uh that they've done preparing this and
putting this to us
just uh also um having been with the
oxford
hiker community board when we listened
to this and
i actually did raise the point that this
was
this drain is historical um
and and i'm just very cautious of
how much more we can cut them off you
know
let's close them down because it just
and the new the
the um people that are buying these
these pieces of land don't actually
understand
the historical part of this water race
and i think it needs to be known
thank you
yes um well i'm not going to
oppose the closure of this because i am
comfortable
with the research that's gone
on behind the recommendation i'm
becoming less comfortable with
with the increasing well it looks like
to me
increasing number of closures and i'm a
bit concerned
if i understood kelly correctly about
the special consultative procedure
which may not be recommending any change
from
how the stock water race operates
at the moment there is a
an environmental benefit to the
leakiness
of this and it falls
upon the
present property owners nearby to fund
this whereas the environmental benefit
is across the district particularly in
the dilution of
nitrates so it's a default um appears to
be a default managed
aquifer recharge system and that is
increasingly
um brought up around the um zone
committee table
all the time and i would be very much
in favor that when this um
this issue goes out for consultation
that in fact we do look at a
district-wide
rate to entrench the environmental
benefit or certainly put it on the table
for discussion
and in the meantime i'm getting less
comfortable with
approving closures of bits and pieces
until we're
able to look at it
in its entirety and
consider whether we move from
a property owner
rating and acknowledging of course that
it is a stock water system
but in fact right from the word go with
this
it is confirming a an environmental
benefit
to recharge the aquifer and that has
become
really uh really important and
the farming community is acknowledging
that
all the time and is through the water
zone so i don't think
uh plus there is also um
recharge of uh whether appropriate or
not recharge of
of some of the major streams through
rangiora like the north brock
we approve we have uh approved the
closure of the race that goes into the
headwaters of that
that stream it hasn't as far as i
understand being enacted fully because
there is concern from people downstream
and urban rangiora they want that stream
to continue to flow
whereas runanga don't want that
contamination of the water so there
there are quite a few issues that i
would be
very keen to see um in the special
consultative procedure
it's as i said it's gone from being a
purely
stock race a stock water race to
something
different and i think we'd be burying
our heads in the sand if we don't
acknowledge that and consult with our
community
on the wider issues here when we do go
out for consultation
thank you
while i'll be supporting this motion i
am concerned
about the comments from feedback from
people we've got um
one there it's hard to mow and
would like it filled in which goes
against the um
the drainage side of in floods another
one there's saying
um it creates spillage and flooding
and then another one says i haven't seen
water flowing it for
some time so there's conflicting
evidence from the feedback and three of
those people there wanting it filled in
completely
i don't know whether they know the
consequences if it did get filled in
completely for the drainage do they know
um that it's not going to get filled or
sections of it's not going to but there
is going to be drainage
parts um and compass in that area
um but once it's closed
all these water races they won't be
opened again
we've lost it probably forever because
it's going to be very hard
and um we don't know what the um
the flow-on effect is going to be from
closing these water races
um in the long term until we get some
bitter knowledge on this um ground full
um
scenario so there is conflicting
feedback there
um i'm just wee bit concerned that's all
thank you again chair paul airport
covered with most of what i was going to
say
i just make the point that you you can't
call this a managed aquifer recharge
system if it hasn't had any water in it
for two to three years
all right thank you so so
um i'll um
ask those in favor of this
recommendation please say aye
against carrie thank you
oh a bigger pardon
i thought there was enough conversation
around it
keep us on track yes yeah yeah
well we have to because we've got time
stone
restraints here so um now we're just
going to call
colin to come forward please thank you
this is on um water
water strategy conservation 5.2
thank you so the purpose of this report
is to update um the utilities and
roading committee on the performance
against our water conservation strategy
performance measures and also
to adopt the updated water conservation
strategy document
um so the just as a little bit of
background the water conservation
strategy was first adopted
in 2010 and at the time it was written
that it
was intended to be updated every three
years
since that time and the purpose of the
document was to
to ensure that there were measures in
place to make sure that water was used
wisely and conservatively in the
district um
it hasn't actually been updated since uh
which is why a review was undertaken
so it started off um the initial trigger
is that there was an improvement project
from last the last long-term plan cycle
to
review the reasonable water use
calculations within the document
and so we we undertook that review and
it was
predominantly just re-inputting data
into an equation that have been
been derived for how to how to work out
reasonable water use
and then also we made some updates to it
in terms of information
better data that was available on stock
numbers in the district which feeds into
reasonable use on rural schemes
but then once we once we started feeding
that update into the water conservation
strategy document it became apparent
that
the document was quite out of date um
in terms of some of the simple things
you know
it referred to schemes that no longer
existed because they'd been merged into
other schemes and
and just some of the data being 10 years
old so that's what triggered a more
comprehensive review of the document
so the the review mainly consisted of
updating that data so it was current and
also
um just making sure that the
explanations of the the way that we
undertake
the practices in our current still so as
an example at the time the first
water conservation strategy document was
produced
that we hadn't um attempted to measure
leakage in the district at that time it
just set out that we would do that so we
have been doing that now
annually for the last 10 years so we're
able to report on
the um how we've actually done it that
and then update with
with genuine results from that so
you can see in table one of the report
some of
the performance against the performance
measures in the
document um so i'll just run through
those so
one of the key ones is the percentage of
real water loss
from the networked reticulation system
that
this is a mandatory performance measure
we report on
annually um the target is 22 and the
assessed leakage
for the last assessment period was 25
so we didn't achieve that target um
which i i can i'll run through the table
then i'll talk about
um some of the reasons behind that um
a second performance measure was the
leakage in terms of liters per
connection per day
the target was 240 which we met
on the district as a whole but on a
scheme-by-scheme basis some
schemes did and some schemes didn't um
but we had since the report around this
time last year
said that we would replace that liters
per connection per day performance
measure
with the infrastructure leakage index as
our primary target
because this um nationally and
internationally
the infrastructure leakage index has
been adopted as a more meaningful
measure of leakage because it doesn't
just look at how many connections you
have but also the
amount of pipe worker scheme has the
amount of connections
um and the pressure the scheme operates
at so in terms of that measure we
achieved a b result for the scheme as a
whole which was
was um what our target was to be b
or better and then in terms of
reasonable water use
so those those three measures above all
to do with leakage the next
um two are to do with whether or not
we're
consuming a reasonable amount of water
so in terms of the average
the actual use on an average day we
performed well
at about 68 and then on a peak day we're
at about 98
of what we consider to be the reasonable
limit
and so what that's really saying is day
to day
we're using a reasonable amount of or
a little less than a reasonable amount
of water so we're doing well on that
measure and on peak days
that's when the usage can be quite high
so although we met our target across the
district there were some schemes
that had higher use than others um
and then the final measure was that we
um
in terms of allocated units of flow um
that
that all properties are restricted
schemes received their correct
allocation
and at the moment we're reporting that
as insufficient data because to report
that we meet that we
would have to have an asset management
system where we knew
the exact um flow through every
connection in in the district which we
are working towards with the
amos project but we don't yet have that
implemented and have the data flowing
back into the assets well enough to
confidently give us our give ourselves a
hundred percent score
on that mark meaning we're not able to
report that as achieved yet
although we do we do undertake
restricted schemes
um i restrict checks on all our
restricted schemes we just can't
quite produce the reports to give to say
we we're at 100
until we gather that data in a smarter
way than we currently are
um so
just to talk a little bit about the
leakage
um measures that we didn't meet and
some of the next steps to address them
in terms of the percentage of real water
loss
as i've talked about before one of the
big challenges
is not necessarily that we have
excessive amount of leakage but on a on
unmated schemes
it can be quite challenging to get an
accurate measurement of that
and so we we use
the um the best tools we have and and
try to reference
methods that are that are outlined on
how we should calculate
leakage but um they tend to be a little
bit conservative
so we've started to look at better ways
to measure leakage
as a first step um so an example
on work we've done in the last 12 months
fernside
scheme used to be reported based on
night flows at about 60
leakage when we we put flow meters out
on
all the connections that were set up
where you could easily just screw a flow
meter on into flow balance which is
a much more accurate way to assess
leakage so we looked at the amount of
water leaving the station
looked at the amount of water entering
each property that had a meter
um and then that instantly dropped our
leakage from 60
to about 30 percent so we didn't fix a
single leak in doing that but we halved
our leakage by
gathering better data so that was quite
encouraging
and it's quite achievable on a small
scheme that has about 80 connections but
it's
it would become very expensive to do
that across the district
to go to universal measuring so it won't
work for all schemes but it's something
we can
implement on other smaller schemes um
that currently
um don't meet our our targets for
leakage and some examples of that are on
table
three where we've got a scheme by scheme
analysis so the ones we're going to look
at next would be points road and gary
mere
we can meter them for a period of
several months and then look at
do a flow balance and i expect to see
those numbers reduced to some extent
um and then mandeville is the other
scheme we'd like to look at but that has
about
900 connections so um
that method may not be as cost effective
on mandeville so what we're looking at
there
is um is to better inform one of our
other assumptions which is
um on a on an on-demand scheme you
look at your flow in the middle of the
night or 2 a.m
and and you say that flow the the
majority of that flow must be leakage
because no
there's very few people up at 2 a.m um
having showers and using water and that
kind of thing
so that's that's the general philosophy
but behind our night flow
method and it's it works
reasonably well although i think still a
little conservatively
on our on demand schemes but on our
restricted schemes
you can see across the board they all
have higher reported leakage
and that's because restrictive schemes
are designed that people do actually use
or receive water even when they're not
using it because their tanks will
continue to fill up after they go to bed
and go to sleep until they reach full
so it's definitely conservative on those
schemes so the way we're looking at
addressing that is putting out some
smarter meters on selected properties
to get a um a better figure for our
assumed night leakage per property so if
we gather enough data on
you know at 2am the average property
uses x
liters per second and we extrapolate
that out across the scheme
that will increase our genuine night
usage amount and by doing that it will
decrease our leakage amount
so we're we've just got 10 meters going
out in mandeville soon to start to build
up some data
and then we as we click that data we'll
we'll assess how valuable that data's
going to be in terms of
refining our understanding of actual
leakage so um
once we've done a small pilot trial
we'll then assess the value of that and
look at whether or not we extend it
and we could then move them around the
district and get better
night flow genuine night use values
across all their restricted schemes
so again we expect that we'll reduce the
numbers we're reporting for those
schemes
and then the final thing we're starting
to look at for
some of the larger schemes such as
rengar and kaiapoi is some
form of pressure management so
leakage is is a directly correlated with
pressure so if you run a scheme at a
really high pressure
um any small leaks you've got the water
will flow out of them much faster so
you'll get higher leakage rates so
at the moment our schemes aim to operate
at the pressure that the scheme will
need
at the at the hottest
the peak time of the peak day of the
year so when you've got everyone wants
to use water we operate at a certain
pressure and that allows for losses
throughout the scheme but all the other
times of the year when people
aren't but when it's not your peak hour
of the peak day
the scheme doesn't actually need as much
pressure as we're giving it so we we're
looking at whether we can reprogram our
pumps to look at the flow and then if
the flow isn't
isn't as high the scheme um the pressure
leaving the station can be a little
lower and then as demand comes up the
pressure can come up to compensate so
it will basically mean that we don't
have to pressurize our scheme
like it's the middle of summer all year
round
and then that will what that will mean
is that our night flows will drop
and we'll ideally um we think be able to
report lower night flow values and
therefore lower percentages of water
lost
without having any impact at peak times
um so that's just an example of the key
things we're looking at doing going
forward to address some of those results
i talked about
um one other thing before i take
questions
is i thought i should point out measures
that were considered in the 2010
document and not included then and have
still not been included now
and that's volumetric charging or full
volumetric metering of
um water connections so i think
a key reason is that this
is really just considered to be an
update of the data within the water
conservation
strategy document and to cover off the
strategies we currently use and i wasn't
looking to start to introduce
significant new measures such as
volumetric charging because that would
be quite a comprehensive process in
itself if it was
going to be looked at so it definitely
is
there's good evidence to say that the
day you introduce volumetric charging
your water use will drop and also you
would get more accurate
results with your leakage because you
know exactly how much is being used and
how much has been lost
but it does also come at a cost and when
that was looked at in 2010
it was um i think around the
nine million dollar mark to meet every
property in the district so
and at the time it concluded that the
the amount of money you'd spend on in
installing all those meters wouldn't
offset the savings you'd make
so um we
what we're looking at doing is we can
review the numbers
that in terms of the costings from that
um
that work in 2010 were actually leading
up to the 2010 document so i think it
was around 2007
and that could form part of the three
waters rating review
conversation of if it was desired to be
included in that or it um
it wouldn't need to so i guess the um
the
if we can produce some more numbers on
that that'll help um
council to make a decision on whether we
want to explore that further or whether
we keep the same conclusion from 2010
so the the point really is we're not
this report isn't seeking to
change that one way or the other but it
is something we could consider
in the future so
yeah the key resolution is just to
acknowledge the um
the performance over the last year and
also
to adopt the updated water conservation
strategy so happy to take any questions
yeah the first one up as counselor
you will yeah
look your last point is actually
covering off some of the things i mean
back in 2008 when we actually had a look
at this we talked about
the offset and it was going to be more
cost effective
to save water by through leakage
stopping liquids
than it was to put water meters on
reason we have this
you're telling us that the target of 22
percent hasn't been met
so i just while accepting this report
and it's a good report don't get me
wrong
i'm just wondering if we're at that
point where we need to be looking at
that
given the three waters change
number one but number two we clearly
haven't achieved what we set out to
achieve which was to
save more water by stopping leaks than
putting
the measurements on people that they're
volumetric
and and clearly this is saying they
haven't reached 22
so we haven't done that so my question
is are we at the point
10 years down the track which is
actually 12 by the time we first
started to discuss this and i accept you
you guys went here
because at time we really seriously
looked at that
i i think um there are
there are definitely benefits that we
would see
not you know putting in meters doesn't
stop leaks
but it help it would help us actually
know exactly how many leaks we have
rather than the night flow method which
although there's
a bit of science behind it is
essentially guessing that at
a certain time at night the the water
demand is leak
so it's it would help report much more
accurately leakage and i think that
would mean that we'd report less
but it wouldn't actually just installing
meters
wouldn't stop our or
you know it wouldn't change the amount
of actual actual water leaking out of
our pipes but it would give us a much
better understanding of that
it would though reduce the amount of
water people consume
and i think um there's been reports
saying that it can cut
consumption by about 15 to 20 percent so
it would help with some of the
reasonable water use
targets um so it would help with that
but i guess it really is a consider a
bit of a benefit cost analysis of
um would the would the benefits be worth
the cost of doing it
and that some i think the next
step would be for us to bring a report
actually outlining those costs and bring
them up to date
so i can't i probably can't say
definitively right now
you know we should do it or we shouldn't
do it i i can
give a feel for what sorts of benefits
we'd get but um
i think the costs are quite out of date
now that i think that would be a next
step
before making a recommendation on that
well
just two very quick questions number one
if we did have volumetric
measuring and we found out where the
leaks were surely that's something that
council would
would work on without it we don't know
where the leaks are in the pipe so we
can't work on where they are
yeah so surely that would
my question is surely that would help us
actually do something about leakage
as opposed to not knowing and number the
the second question around that is
around the three waters of review
and you know if we're too uh should we
spend time on
researching this or should we just hang
off and let the government do it i mean
that's that's
the question behind i was hoping i'd get
that out of the first one but
then what
yes i think with the three waters review
there's probably
i could come up with arguments either
way i know i could say well you know
it would help demonstrate that we have
really good unders
understanding of how all our systems
work and it would put us in a good
place to um to demonstrate what a good
job we're doing but at the same time you
could argue if it's a foregone
conclusion
then why do it and why not wait for it
to be
implemented by someone else so i think
it potentially depends on how
how you would assume the three orders
review is going to
pan out um yeah sorry
that's the very non-committal answer
yeah um flow on peak days calculations
and where do we compare at the air flows
with other towns or or where did we
compare that with
the amount of water being used um that's
a good
question i haven't provided a comparison
with other districts in here
it's it's easy to provide a comparison
on uh the types of measures that are in
the
for example the water new zealand
national performance review and
documents like that which are percentage
of water losses and
infrastructure leakage index um there's
not
a universal um
or not that i'm aware of a measure that
we could compare for those measures
that's
that's assessed consistently nationally
so
um the answer is i don't know
and the other question is um
for getting our water losses um um
leakages we're calling it it may not
actually be leakages it might be um
garden auto systems that come on at um
one o'clock two o'clock in the morning
to water people's lawns
because we have got a very garden
orientated
um towns around the
areas and probably bigger sections of
what um
a lot of other areas have so it may not
actually be all water
leakage loss it might be just um we're
not familiar with
um what's happening out there is that
sound is it
could be yeah yeah i think in in general
i'm sure that is a big part of it
um when we measure our or look at our
networks on other metrics our pi page is
generally very good
our pipe break rates is pretty good as
well
um so um
there's a lot of data that suggests that
pipe networks are actually in very good
condition
so i think um you're probably correct
that that our leakage is probably
quite good but we just don't without it
it's very difficult to get evidence to
prove that without measuring what
everyone's doing at night and the only
way to measure that is to
put a meter on every house and then read
it every year so
it's really um a question
of how much can we achieve without that
versus the cost of doing it um i think
from a financial point of view
um the cost of
you know if you did that if you meet
everything and your your measured
leakage went from 25
to 15 you've spent a whole lot of money
on meters but you still haven't actually
stopped consuming any water you've just
now can confidently report a better
number so you haven't actually saved
necessarily any money in there and and
um counselor atkinson might be right you
m
it might help you find some leaks as
well but it's not neces i think the
the main benefit um
would be equity if it's if you then use
it for charging and people pay based on
how much they use
and also giving us better data to report
and a better understanding of our
systems but i don't think it would be
financial in terms of lowering the cost
of the systems by
you know saving money and our water is
still the production cost of water is
still
quite cheap in the district as a whole
so it wouldn't be a financial
based decision i don't think but more
either inequity or
just understanding the networks type
benefit l
um page 52 colin the table there on the
the urban flows why is waikoku's
percentage figure so high of
actual versus reasonable is that is that
a true figure or is that
does that relate to what you've alluded
to with complications of data collection
um let me just
catch up sorry
uh i think that so in terms of our
reasonable water use calculations they
take into account
a number of factors like every through
or or urban or as a stock or there's not
but what it doesn't take into account
is the soil type or the land area so my
theory is waikoku beach generally have
quite large
sections and quite sandy soil so
probably
people there like their gardens and they
it
flows through the sand and and probably
to maintain a gut
in there you know we could introduce
some we did consider
having some kind of factor in terms of
what's reasonable and saying if you've
got a bigger garden you should be
that's reasonably think you would water
your garden more than someone with a
small section but at the moment we
we don't have that factor in there
because uh yeah
on the other hand you could argue well
no one should be
having a you shouldn't have a thousand
square meter garden because that's
um not good use of water so i guess it's
it's depends what we think is a
legitimate reason to use more water and
what isn't and that's one question
where um that's
at the moment the equation doesn't
consider that a reason you know a reason
to use more water but i think
it is you know if you look at the other
schemes such as oxford
and um ahoka
and gary mir they're kind of the schemes
where people do have larger sections and
probably enjoy their gardening more than
potentially somewhere like rancho or
chipotle with their it's
there's more of the you know typical
kind of smaller
sort of 400 600 800 square meter
sections than they're quite large ones
so i
i think that's probably the biggest
factor
okay so with regard to depressurizing
the supplies
as a keen gardener who works shift work
i'll often water my garden at night well
will i notice
the loss the drop in pressure
i will definitely monitor that so i
think the theory is when
on a peak day um our water headworks has
to have pressure up here to make sure
you get pressure
you know of that lower level so we might
offer it at 500 kpa to give you 300
um because there's the more water you're
sending out you get losses through the
network so the pressure
slowly drops but then on any other day
where
we don't have that high demand we'll be
sitting at 500 kpa and you'll be getting
500 kpa in your garden so on a
what we're looking at doing is whatever
that minimum pressure target is you
on the peak day the station will come up
to achieve that so you you will never
get less
water pressure than your minimum you
just won't necessarily get that
over pressure that you don't need on the
cooler months
um or at 2am where you know
you know very few people are using water
so it shouldn't
get to a point where it's noticeable
it's more of a subtle
change that we just don't apply that
pressure when nobody needs it
yeah no yep long
explain to no sandra thanks
uh thank you madam chair um are you
proposing
to um update um
you know cost of metering and all the
issues that you've
raised um with some measuring leakage
for
a the ltp or
our own three waters rating review
independent of of doing anything we see
that may
be of interest to the wider three waters
review yeah i think that's what's been
suggested that as a minimum
will bring you figures on what it would
cost
to implement metering um and
for the ltp well the last suggestion on
that was for that to help inform the
three waters rating review which is
after the ltp so
um yeah because i think it's too
big an issue to say now you know for the
ltp should we introduce
universal measuring and volumetric
charging but we can start to gather that
data
to inform the writing review after that
two interrelated questions are are some
of these
um connections on these schemes
perhaps used for irrigation by any
chance
uh they could be they could only really
handle domestic garden irrigation
this you couldn't get enough through a
15 mil connection to
you know irrigate a paddock or something
like that okay because um
basically i i note that you are only
three percent
off of your target and as as robbie has
his
and and paul have also raised my
question is
that um could it not be that um
there are in fact people who are
watering because there is a raised
awareness of the appropriate times
to to water the most effectively um i
know with our lifestyle block group for
instance we had somebody come in and
talk to us about that very thing that
you know
watering in a howling norwest on a hot
day is a silly thing to do it's a waste
of water
so could there be people using using
timers or or maybe even some small
commercial
um like say glass house operation not
glass house but um
tunnel house operations and things that
are that are possibly using this
um these water supplies that so it's not
in fact leakage at all because if we're
talking about
leakage versus the expense and
and trouble of putting in meters um how
do we actually know what this water is
being used for when it could very well
be people just
just watering at a more effective time
of night yeah and that's the
that's a key thing you've picked up one
did it
part of the education is exactly that to
address the peak use you say to people
don't water it
when it's sunny water you know put on a
timer and water at 11 pm or
2am or whenever so that's good
for the network and everything we don't
have to oversize all our pipes and
things to meet really high peak
demands but then if every friend does
water at night then it looks like our
night flows high and it makes us look
bad
in our night flown out analysis so um
i guess the only thing is the impact of
it is probably not
that significant because we look in
winter
at night so then um you wouldn't get as
many people watering then but maybe
there's some who just have a timer on
they sit in the summer and they just
keep it going year round because they
don't
i don't know um so i guess it you know
it probably sounded like the same point
over and over but it without mises you
don't know on a house by house basis
what people are doing
with what we're looking at a mandible
we're trying to get a typical value that
we could apply for this is a typical
genuine night use on a restricted scheme
because there are published
figures on typical night use on on
demand schemes that we
input into our equation but um nothing
typical on a restricted scheme so we
just
we either you have to collect that data
yourself
or you have to make assumptions about it
and at the moment we're
making assumptions but trying to collect
a little bit of restrictive schemes to
make it a little bit smarter so so you
are actually
measuring this at 2 a.m in the winter
yeah
sorry i missed that yeah sorry we
measure float constantly
every scheme 24 7 and then we we look at
the minimum
flow at night and at winter to see when
you know the pretty much the lowest
patch we can find
so your leakage rate percentage has
actually come from a winter measurement
yep
yep all right thank you
any more questions paul you want to move
here
thank you so it's paul moving in our
second
thank yeah and i think we're exactly a
good report
and um i think um you're probably right
on assumptions
because um i believe likes of waikoku
they are going to be using more water
um because of the ground what have you
and we have got a quite a
um a flower orientated gardening
community um
and i would be concerned if we um
started spending a lot of
money on metering and found out we
actually haven't got as much um
losses as what we think through due to
leakages because we actually have got a
good
um pipe system around the community and
you know i think we just need to um
carry on all that
i'd be a wee bit concerned about
lowering the pressure because
that could show false evidence because
you lower the pressure you're actually
going to get less
water out of your any of your garden
hose as well so
it's a trade-off lowering pressure
you're going to get you know less
liters per second example so
um it may not be give the bees and these
but
i think good report and um yeah
now do you wish to say no neville
are you look i'm going to play devil's
advocate here and something for us to
think about this is a good report
and you know it's in front of us but
we've got the three waters review going
on
are we spending a lot of money here that
we don't need to spend at the moment
the government's going to spend anyway
and
i.e whether we're going to need meters
may not be up to us maybe up to the
government
whether we go whether we need to monitor
this any further because we have the
evidence that we have now which is very
accurate
you know do you heat your bets for a
couple of years pull your money out of
this space
um for your research leave it alone
until such times we know what uh what
three waters is doing now i mean
that's playing the devil's advocate but
i'm putting it out there there's some
savings to be made here
if we don't do anything until we find
out what the government's doing
went to make a comment yes
i wasn't actually going to say anything
but but in response to
councillor atkinson it's not we
around this table it's in fact the costs
will be
our rate payers so to me it's a material
whether we wait um until three waters
review comes in we've got
and you know no i don't necessarily
believe this i'll say it
it's never cheaper to do something now
than in the future because we've heard
that argument all the time so
i'd be interested in finding out um
more accurately what is the situation as
far as
leakage goes and the other question that
has struck me is whether our
leaving it as it is and the calculations
that we're making that
right now are going to be acceptable to
the three waters review and we're going
to see
our rate payers forced
to front up and pay for
something that we could perhaps
look at and progressively um
well certainly consult on and
progressively
look to implement so i mean it's it's
not
a saving to us as a council um
i don't know until i see the data
data that is going to be presented in a
report
whether in fact i would consider it to
be
a good sustainable move
in across our district or not
so i mean i don't buy that argument
that i would need more data if i was
going to buy that argument and
welcome the report that um
colin's talking about but he's not
talking about
now he's talking about for 2022
when in fact we're going to look at this
district um our own um
our own three waters rating review
um so yeah i would welcome data
sooner rather than later so that and i
think
we would be we may be required or
we or some other entity will require
the work to be done but the guts of it
is
it comes back to our ratepayers having
to
or not having to front
up to pay for some of this so i'd like
to get my head
round the sooner the better as i've said
exactly
what potentially could be involved
because as i said
don't know whether our calculation here
is
acceptable um and i wouldn't want to see
suddenly that um our ratepayers are
going to have to
front up with the cost of metering and
our
leakage which we we think you've
potentially within kiwi of achieving
something
um acceptable
and personally i find if 22 liquid
leakage isn't acceptable at all but
i'd rather have that information in
front of me
sooner than later
council williams do you wish to have a
writer reply
yeah um i actually agree with council x
and we shouldn't really be spending a
big cost for
better data because um i believe the
staff what they say we've got good
piping systems
around the um the area um
we get leakage because if there's a fire
the fire brigade's practicing they pump
out the hydrants
that's that's classes a bit of a leakage
if we do the um
at particularly different times and and
what have you
um so i i just trust our staff that
they've told me we've got some really
good pipe work around there
good pipe work doesn't cause some leaks
i think it's because we've got um
uh areas where we're using a lot of
water because we've got
good gardens around the um areas
and um we've got a lot of people now
been
educating to use the water their lawns
at night time and
all that type of scenario so so i
i think we've got a reasonably good
system now so
of reporting i'm going to
um the recommendation from a
to i is all in favor please say hi
against carrick thank you thank you
all right you're on again
thank you thank you very much so this
report is
for the um to request approval to submit
the ohoka water safety plan
to our drinking water association so
this is another plan that has come up
for its five-year
anniversary meaning it needs to be
updated um
just to give a very short overview of
the scheme i think
this scheme is quite a good candidate to
get an approved plan
um it's got the infrastructure is
relatively new
and in good condition we've got a secure
source
and we've got chlorine in place
the the one key thing that's been
highlighted
in the water safety plan that we
recommend addressing is to upgrade the
tanks
partly because they're older concrete
ones which tend to um
not have a great life in terms of before
they start
being prone to leakage and while the
chlorine helps with that it's
it's still better not to have the risk
of leaking tanks in the first place
um and also in terms of the hours of
emergency storage
it doesn't meet our performance measure
so we we recommend putting in some
some more storage there and that um that
was part of the basis for including that
as one of the
proposed stimulus projects which will be
covered by a report
um coming on the council agenda soon as
well so hopefully
um we can address that one
key recommendation through that project
which
um which will also help um with the hoka
scheme who have
funded their their main upgrade recently
um
i think i was going to give a bit of an
update on the general status of water
safety plans as well but kelly covered
that at the start
um in terms of we got a little bit of
feedback from the director general of
house on
the status across the country which um
yeah as kelly said that there haven't
been any any approved plans under the
new framework although we
we do think some are coming shortly
and we do have a number of outstanding
plans which i
covered so waikoku beach has been
resubmitted
uh cast gary mayer and ahoka have well
cast and gary me
up have been submitted for assessment
but i as far as i know they're not
actively
being assessed um and then i hope
we'll submit after this and then come so
that'll be four plans that we'll have
sitting
with the drinking water assessor once
this one's in then wedding picks us
needs to go back as well as we noted
because it's been submitted and not
approved
so um we are kind of building up
more and more plans that that we need to
get across the line but i think um
the expectation is once there is
a benchmark set for what an approved
plan looks like that will be a huge help
to everyone else who's
who's trying to get to that point so
hopefully we can start to make some
progress once we see
um some approvals come through um
so i'm happy to take any questions thank
you any questions
no questions well i'm going to move this
recommendation
you want recommendation from a to e
someone like just second to place thank
you paul pauline
um thank you very much for this uh um
report
colin i'm very pleased that that
you are putting the hoka water safety
plan for submission for the drinking
water assessor to follow
and that the tanks and the tanks new
tanks will be
put in there under that what was the
scheme called
stimulus yes that's right yes and i'm
really thrilled about that because it's
it's
it's good that hoka is getting a little
bit of
a help because they have spent quite a
substantial amount of money
on to getting their water upgraded so
thank you
i've got nothing to say good report
anybody else question
right all those in favor from a to e
i against carried thank you thank you
gavin would you like to come forward for
your eastern district sewer scheme
and your monitoring report thank you
hello everyone um the support is to
provide the committee an update on the
um compliance monitoring period for the
essence district sur scheme
for 2019-2020
the compliance was achieved fully
achieved
across all the measurements that we
measured for the outflow consent
the impact of cover 19 was minimal the
ward unit did a great
job in maintaining our sampling regime
as required under the consent
the report that was appended to the the
monitoring report has been sent to the
cannery regional council and are still
reviewing it we haven't
received feedback but we expect
them to provide a a full compliance
report back to us
shortly in general the plants have
performed well
over the monitoring period um there's no
unusual events and um
yeah they they are still performing well
and
there's been no significant maintenance
works undertaken just
generally what i'd call housekeeping in
the plants operating as they have been
to date and keeping on top of our
maintenance
anyone wish to ask any questions
right someone like to move it please
thank you paul seconded thank you
robbie do you wish to speak
i just like to think for the report it's
really good to know that we
100 comply so um yeah it's really good
to
hear that thank you just think no
do it does anybody else wish to speak
will we put the recommendation from a to
e
all those in favor please say aye it's
carrick thank you
very much right we're going to move on
then
reports for information don do you want
to come forward
thank you
okay thank you madam chair um
i have really nothing further to add to
this i think that the council
uh the utilities the committee is as
well aware
of the specific issue and the council
has
has discussed it and agreed with
consulting
on the move of the path
to the eastern side that consultation
has begun
um letters have gone out uh and
information is available on the
on the web and we have two uh drop-in
sessions tomorrow
one starting at 7 30 in the morning and
one starting at four in the afternoon
both at the soda cafe uh so
councillors are more than welcome to
come along
and our staff will be there with the
plans
and the flyers and happy to discuss with
any of the
local businesses i think after that we
will have
a much better idea as to
the flavour from the businesses and
that'll form part of a report back
uh as to a final recommendation
following on from the feedback we get
back and i'm happy to take any questions
thank you just would you please just uh
say the times again it was 7 40 in the
morning and
7 30. or 7 30 i'll be late 7
30 till 9 o'clock and
4 30 until 6 pm
thank you and they are just drop in
sessions where people can come at any
time during that stuff will just be
available there'll be no presentation or
anything like that
and no it's not a meeting as such rather
just staff will be available
thank you anyone wish to ask yes
just one question about the drop in
centers
why have we just been waited until now
to be told about
7 30 at soda cafe tomorrow
um should not have council has been
informed away but earlier these drop-in
sessions
we we i knew that they're going to
communicate with the um
the people there the business and all
that but i actually wasn't quite aware
of the actual times of a drop-in session
but you know just can we even future
my apologies i'd understood that all of
the flyers which these times were in had
been circulated to the councillors as
well and if that's not the case i
apologize
that's quite correct we haven't have you
received one no we haven't
but thank you i apologize no that's fine
but thank you very much for letting us
know
the times if anyone wishes to drop in
thank you anybody else wish to have
anything to say someone like to
move this recommendation this report
they're just reports for information
yeah
all right yeah okay right now yeah
well we've got another one here which
will come forward which is um
on their bus stop locations as well
please
so you don't need to talk about it well
i would like perhaps if there was
opportunity for to ask questions
yes
yeah i will be yep yep
i'll take the reports it's red as well
um just one thing i will note is
there were a couple of bus stop
locations where we said we were going to
do additional work
looking at options and we've currently
got that work underway
one of those was outside the plough
hotel on high street
and the other one i think was from
memory on
fuller street um in kaiapoi so we're
just working through those to see
whether there are any further
available options for those bus stops
and then we can update
uh the boards after that thank you just
a question
um what happens if if the neighbor you
you can't you consult with the
neighbours first
yes kathy's carried out quite a lot of
consultation
on those bus stop locations she's
worked with the residents to pick
locations which have the least impact on
residents
um locations where there are pretty
substantial hedges or fences
so that the buses don't cause no noise
or
sight issues for the residents so that's
something that kathy always said it's
front of mind when she's carrying out
those consultations
and just my other question from that one
is the the bus stop that we've recently
put in
in high street that's a really good
style are you are you proposing to
do much the same style as that one
and so is that in reference to the
shelter that's out here on history
so no these are just stops they don't
include
shelters at this stage that shelter was
a particularly high quality one because
of the number of boardings we get there
so in the morning i think we
have well over 20 people boarding at
that bus stop
so that's why a higher level of service
i guess has been provided there
what we will be looking at going forward
is more shelters but that will be
brought to council as part of the ltp
process
haven't really got much to report um
everything sort of um we've got
um the new
contractors and um amir and myself
got a meeting coming up with the um the
site on to um
give our view on what we think the
standard should be
and um apart from that i think everybody
else knows what's
happening around the the area so how
much to report this
time okay
thank you um no have i got much to
report but i'll just
um add that um
i think in preparation for the special
consultative procedure around this stock
water by-law review that
um sophie allen and kate steele are out
at various points
in the system um doing baseline
uh ecological studies on what is
actually
alive and swimming in the um the races
to inform the
review plus i think there is
some a report pending about
supplementing flow in our urban streams
through rangiora
because some residents
at the moment some of these streams as i
indicated earlier
particularly the north brook um is dry
in patches
and has been supplemented
as we know from the stock water race and
the issue of continuing a stock water
race through into an urban area but has
no benefit
and is paid for by property owners
upstream
um that has in the past
um been an issue that we've we've not
um not content is seen as um
as a reason for continuing the water
supply
um so those two things are ongoing so i
understand um the other thing i
i've just i thought of after
we approved the the eastern district's
sewer scheme annual compliance reporters
to actually send that report to the
water zone
committee they're interested in that or
and you can do that either by through
information to land the water or
directly to the
water zone committee but i think they
appreciate looking at that
thank you
yeah um i'm just um quite pleased to
report we've just had about um
100 complying for the um ocean outfield
which is a
a really good result um we've had some
negative feedback from
a few um people about their uh
ocean outfalls and i i only hope we'll
we will look at um
upgrading the system because i think
when we do apply for a new consent on it
we may have to
um the level is going to be up but um
that's good
um we've got a meeting at thursday week
at points road
and hopefully we'll get that um over the
line to um
with the um the people in that scheme
and um so everything's sort of
flowing very good in the wet department
how long does it take you to think that
up well done
thank you very much right uh robbie
please on
solid waste so a joint landfill
committee
and um kate valley committee on the 10th
of august
in christchurch nothing in particular
we approved a hundred thousand dollars
towards some recycling
activity um so nothing came from that
you're all aware of the latest drive
with regard to
the yellow bins so i won't go into that
there was another mishap at the transfer
station
yesterday with a corrections worker who
was tasked to pick up some litter moves
and bins
that fell on her apparently she's hurt
her knee
um but i have nothing more than that
regardless to her condition
okay so that that will come through the
health of safety won't it
thank you all right transport
please me dan um thanks madam chair
um just a few things to update on
um regarding the third lane and all the
work on the
bridge that's taken quite a lot of um
we've had a few meetings around there in
terms of making sure that
cnc are aware of our
community's concerns and keeping the
traffic flowing can i thank our staff
for uh joanne and her team for being out
there and proactively managing that
just by way of not practically managing
but proactively being there to observe
so that changes could be uh implemented
if needed because it was pretty tense
there in that first week and certainly
uh leading into it we were getting a
quite a bit of feedback but that seems
to have settled fairly well
and they're making good progress on the
bridge which is really good
so we had a discussions with cnc and
also jim harland about just making sure
that all the relevant authorities were
making the changes we needed to make
sure that
the progress was progressing well there
um and as you'll have
seen there's been an invite that came
today following a discussion that
jared joanne and myself are in with cnc
and they've invited the council to
come and have a look advanced look at
the new northern corridor
i've extended that to include some of
our gcp
partners as well as mayor of hiranui
uh in our relevant staff so
um with i think that'll be a good
um opportunity to see the new northern
corridor so please let rosie know if
you're
um able to attend um tram road
safety there's been a few issues raised
with that following
um an incident there last week so we had
a zoom call with
jim harland on monday and we've got to
follow up with
the lady that's raised a number of
concerns i've
had a lot of feedback to my facebook
about it i know you probably have
as well nikki because we were tagged
into it and wendy has also shared
some comments so we've got a meeting
coming up with jim in the next gym hana
next week
so with that individual to talk through
the
um comments that she's received and
for that to be considered in terms of
road safety issues there
last week went into environment
canterbury for the unveiling of the new
livery of the buses
um which looked fantastic actually so
progressively over time as the new buses
come on stream or every
um replaced that new livery will be
there it'll be a teal color
moving away from individual coloring
except for the orbiter so that there's
just one network
of bus color so what it'll have on the
side of it isn't just change
um the name so if it's wranger one or
whatever the the root name is it'll be
on it and coincidentally when i was in
there the
um the root name was rangiera1 on the
bus so it was quite good so
i think he can have managed that really
well lintiaca
was involved in
coming up with delivery and there's a
really good story there joanna i'll be
really good
if kathy or the team could share that to
members because
it goes through how that was all
achieved and what all the
um symbols made on the side it was
really good
um last gcp uh
great christchurch meeting is um nikki
will know there was quite a discussion
on bringing in
passion to transport it's it's fair to
say that
whilst we um support um peace and
transport matters coming into the gcp
we've got to be very clear
of agendas and other things that are
going on and
there was certainly some messaging that
came from the city that we've got to
manage
um outside of the meeting before it goes
and i've i've
arranged a meeting with councillor
davidson to talk further about those
because
uh whilst i'm supportive of it coming in
and streamlining it
i'm not supportive of personally
supportive of
pt being removed from environment
canterbury um
so that's not a particular agenda that i
have so i think we just need to be
really clear about
and up front about that paul may have
mentioned
around the meetings tomorrow um that's
the staff have organised around flexton
so there's two one at 7 30 and one at
4 30 tomorrow afternoon at soda cafe so
um thanks to don and the team for their
work and advancing that project
it will be really important for our
district so
look forward to attending those tomorrow
now any questions understanding orders
no
any urgent general business no
our next meeting will be the 17th of
november 2020
in the function room the ring your town
hall
so i will declare this meeting closed at
5 26 but stop we have a
briefing on writing designations
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
you